having a beta this early in development
is crucial because it gives us as
developers the opportunity to react to
the feedback that we get from fans and
actually take that into account as we're
continuing to complete the multiplayer
experience for halo 5 Guardians
the focus of the beta is going to be on
44 arena gameplay which is really you
know getting back to that legacy of
competitive gameplay that's always been
at the heart of halos multiplayer
halo has always been a great competitive
game at that old school feeling of what
is arena shooter for players at each
team controlling weapons on that
controlling the map itself your
teammates being in the right position
the beta will run from December 29
through January 18th for a period of
three weeks we have seven maps we have
three modes the leaven sandbox weapons
that are going to be included and seven
armor sets that you'll be able to
customize your Spartan with looking at
small maps that are really tailored to
four before combat we've also got fair
starts what that means is no one's going
to have a different loadout than the
other person every member of red team is
going to be the same as every member of
the blue team we've got 60 frames per
second which is going to be awesome just
a blistering pace we're gonna have
dedicated servers all these things are
really going to support our goals for
fostering that competitive gameplay
we really want the hailer channel to be
this great complimentary experience with
the beta it so it's not just for us to
be able to push entertainment to you
it's also for the viewer and the player
to kind of give information back to us
we'll be running all of this programming
leading up into the beta and throughout
the beta but you'll also be able to
unlock some things in the beta that
you'll actually be able to carry forward
into halo 5 Guardians
any time you're putting something out
there that you're working so hard on
it's always nerve-racking to have the
first time anybody gets hands-on with
that experience but it's also
invigorating and so we're all just
really excited to get online and play
with the fans and hear their feedback to
help make halo 5 Guardians the best game
it can possibly be
you